all right so maybe we could start with
this question from Stuart Powell and his
question is what's your advice for
non-technical founders as you are a
non-technical founder and solo founder
or a cofounder Prada solo founder but
had a founding team so can do without
them of course okay so yeah maybe the
best way to go about this is you explain
how you made producthunt and then share
some advice for Stuart yeah so I
remember applying to YC and historically
I always realized or thought that YC one
didn't like solo founders and two always
preferred technical founders to begin
with so I was like I don't know if YC is
gonna like me so ended up lying anyway
after you know speaking with Gary and
Alexis and Kat and some others and Kevin
Hale getting their support and you know
when I went into YC when we applied to
YC we already had some traction where we
had some proof that people wanted this
thing so what does that actually mean
like some meaning roughly what number I
don't remember the exact numbers it was
obviously still very small cuz it was
pretty early days but we were seeing
about 50 percent month-over-month growth
in total like top-line user visits and
that was consistent for the first I
don't know two three four months and so
that really demonstrated that oh wow
this person he is single founder and
he's non-technical but somehow this
thing is growing and people seem to want
it and when you're you know whether
you're non-technical or typing or
whatever it may be if you can
demonstrate data like that it's hard to
argue it's hard to say that oh actually
no this isn't useful if you're
demonstrating that people are using your
product and that's that's the ultimate
proof and so when people who are
non-technical founders come to you now
what do you advise him like how do you
how do you figure out how to make
prototypes and get something out the
door there's a lot of ways that you can
validate ideas or build products without
really coding anything product on it was
an email list in the beginning so really
I was I was forced not being an engineer
to not spend weeks and weeks building
something that maybe something that
people didn't want instead I was like
okay well what can I build and then what
experience could I provide that would
maybe validate or test whether people
wanted this so built this email list
sent it out got a few hundred
subscribers initially and it took me 20
minutes to set
so it was like the ultimate MVP in from
a product standpoint I was like email is
actually a great place to put content to
re-engage people because they you know
our audience people and technology they
use email every single day so for
technical there are non-technical people
you know things like email or hacking
things together with like type form
actually is a really good tool to almost
like create a product essentially you
can put like type form and stripe
together and actually collect money
that's the ultimate test yeah like you
can get people to pay you money for
something then you're like well wow they
clearly want this mm-hmm so I think
there's a lot of things you can do
without doing any coding and even if you
are technical it's actually in many
cases wise to start testing with those
types of non-technical tools so that you
can put something out there sooner and
earlier yeah and do you find that will
you just launch ship like this new
product or a new feature I guess yeah
are people using that to beta test stuff
or are these like fully functioning
products yeah it's a combination of
everything really so we we built ship in
in many ways it's basically a tool kit
for makers and startups two one
announced new products that they're
creating collect emails for those
products and then get feedback and
communicate with those users okay so a
lot of these things we were actually
doing a product on for several years
through you know various tools like
MailChimp using type forum just
basically sending out you know
screenshots and and usually actually
envisioned as a great tool to get up and
annotate screenshots and get feedback so
you're sort of hacking all these tools
together and we're like okay well people
on products and are continually asking
us like how can I use product to start
getting initial users or feedback for my
product before I'm ready to launch so we
built ship and we're seeing people use
it for everything we were just talking
earlier about like Casey and I stand in
his new app they used it to start
capturing interests or beam panels or
new apps that's coming out soon them and
other similar people are using it then
seed it with beta users to get actual
feedback on the product so long story
short our goal is like create something
that people could use to start
generating demand and communicating with
our audience and ultimately what I
believe is is like the more you can
communicate with your audience make them
feel involved in the process and get
feedback from them
the higher chance you are in building
some that people want or a good product
ultimately mm-hmm and I think this also
relates to another question which is
which is a little blunt but Diego asked
is there a business model in producthunt
are you trying to go in that direction
with the ship product or yeah what's the
plan yeah so historically we've never
really charged for anything yeah outside
of a long long time ago once upon a time
we did post for charge people for job
postings but then we we stopped that to
focus entirely on building the community
in the audience now we're shifting some
of our focus towards monetization and
ship is actually the first thing that
we've directly charged for outside of
those initial tests and the fun part is
yesterday we launched we set up of
course a slack bot to notify whenever
someone gives us money and so those are
like the best notifications we're
getting it's like wow this person just
subscribed you know for like $249 a
months this thing that we built it's
like that's awesome and I woke up this
morning to a bunch more notifications I
was like this is amazing
so our strategy going forward here and
especially in q4 is to think more about
what are the things that we can build
and provide that people like so much
that they're willing to pay for and ship
is showing a lot of promise and you know
helping startups with you know
communicating and marketing and so on
another piece that we are working on
that hasn't really shown that you'll
start to see soon is also leveraging the
community and the platform we've built
to connect companies with talent so now
that we're inside of AngelList
there's this whole a list talent
platform it's a great place to recruit
great talent and we also improbably have
a lot of talented engineers designers
marketers a so on that might want to
join companies that you know we're
launching a part-time there's a nice
opportunity to make those connections
and as a result generate some revenue
out of that without being super
heavy-handed and showing pop-ups and
already having stuff yeah it makes us
see that from Protestant yeah yeah yes
maybe maybe audio playing videos with
with sound and everything about will see
well you guys do email well but you
could like push it even further have you
always so you like it was first email
list have you always believed that email
was going to be the most effective way
for you to stay in touch with people
yeah it's always been
you know a lot of people say email is
dead emails dumb I don't like email
people use email all the time though and
it's it's a great plant channel for
re-engagement back in 2013 or 12 I can't
remember I wrote in I used to write a
lot and block a lot and wrote about an
article called email first startups
actually is one of the early articles
that I had on hacker and who's that guy
oh cool on the home page I was like well
this is cool people are reading my thing
and it was basically just outlining
various startups that started office
emails to begin with angellist
ironically was one of those like Angeles
MVP essentially was an email digests but
yeah it was an email list in the
beginning and and it's a very simple way
to MVP something and see if people
actually open it and click on it it's
also very malleable so every single
morning or every day when you send that
email you can change the copy you can
try different things whereas when you
put something in code it's a lot harder
to change in most cases it's fairly
stagnant so when you're sort of testing
ideas emails great channel for that
that's awesome
we own a bunch of questions around the
YC application it's like application
season right now oh yeah that's right
yeah a few of those actually David Adom
ooh I might be mispronouncing his last
name tell us about a time you
successfully hacked an on computer
system to your advantage this is a YC
application question I forgot what I
okay I can't remember if this was my
answer in the YC application or not it
may have been so as a kid I was always
interested in working on different
projects and trying to turn trying to
turn something into money I hated
working for money for time like I hated
getting paid hourly because if I did a
terrible job or an awesome job I got
paid the same whatever $6 or $7 an hour
so I was always trying to find
entrepreneurial ways to make money and
one of those was actually selling things
on eBay when I was kid so I would browse
fatwallet and slick deals which of these
like communities and forms that people
would post different deals that you can
get on usually electronics and it would
usually involve things with rebates
price matching and all these like hacks
that you'd have to like work around some
of them slightly gray hat is like a
little bit Shady
in any case what I would do is browse
those websites daily and then fine
I used to buy things that were maybe 30
or 40 percent off MSRP and then buy them
and then sell them on eBay mm-hmm and I
think I sold it wasn't a lot like one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars maybe
two hundred thousand dollars and like
merchandise but I really wasn't it was
almost like it enjoyable for me to find
and hunt for these things and then make
money on it it didn't even matter how
much money I made for me it was more
like oh I could turn this thing into
like this idea into money yeah and so I
did that through I don't know high
school and some in college that's great
so that was fun
there was a whole plan of money episode
about that yeah people going to was a
year two ago Toys R Us and reselling on
Amazon
oh yeah there's this whole culture of
like that little arbitrage but just get
enough volume here's another one what
were the main points you were trying to
get across in your YC application and
interview this is from Phil yeah I think
looking back on it I believe that you
know part of it was I was going in there
again as single founder non-technical so
I had that concern and so my approach
really was to communicate in and sort of
sell them on this this vision an idea
that we need a place in the internet a
place to discover all these products
being built you know I think the
audience that YC you know partners they
understood the pain point that makers
and startups are seeing when it comes to
discovery so I felt that that was you
know a strong thing to capture and to
kind of double down on but really was
just about selling the vision of like
how do we create a place where in a
world where we have all these products
people can discover the best ones I mean
really other than that it was also just
like communicating confidence in some
ways I think you go into that interview
people are nervous I was nervous you
have these I think everyone's freaking
out yeah yeah in my case is like three
to four people in front of you drooling
you with questions
I remember Sam Sam Allen was one of them
and it's just like you cut me off a
couple times and I came prepared knowing
that so I was like okay if they cut me
off I'm just gonna move on and you know
tried to be succinct and clear yeah I
think that's psychologically very
difficult for people and at that point
is one of my main points of advice when
they're asking like pre-interview make
you can't let that ruin your flow and
ruin your energy a lot of people start
to get defensive when they're
interrupted and then it just spirals out
of control
oh yeah it's like a weird psychological
tactic yeah especially if you have more
multiple founders - it's the dynamic of
how he speaks when and how do you make
sure that you don't look like you're
fighting the last thing you want is two
founders to look like they already have
found her problems yeah ten minute
interview yep which can be challenging
yep all right oh yeah I did have a
question about a podcast discovery mm-hm
so where do you see that going right now
like obviously you guys have a podcast
section yes and no we actually kind of
quietly killed podcasts oh yeah so this
is some of the history and product and
is you know early on we of course have
been targeting the tech community and
and we made some mistakes admittedly on
some of the execution of some kind of
category expansions we went into like
games and books and podcast was like
this sort of fourth category that we
introduced and in hindsight it was very
clear why podcasts didn't belong in our
current content ecosystem one podcast uh
you know discovering the we consume
podcast is wildly different than you
discover an app or a product it's also
very frequent like there's a new podcast
every week or more than that so that
good dynamics didn't really work with
just shoving it into the pradhan
community mmm however the direction and
the opportunity that we were tackling
with podcast specifically I think is
still something I would love to see and
there's a YC company called breaker
which you probably know of which in many
ways is executing on the way that we
would have or wanted to execute on
podcast if we focused on podcasts mmm
ultimately we decided podcast is not our
business like we're focused on product
discovery primarily and we're gonna stop
doing that breakers approaching it in a
similar way where they're leveraging
community and enabling you know people
to discover podcasts in a new and
different way through other people and
Friends so I think I mean from a market
perspective I don't see a world where we
don't have something like that in
podcasts like a place where people can
discover and engage and almost geek out
about podcast together now
to date those exist in like on reddit to
some extent and various places on the
internet but there's no there's no
leader in that space right now no well I
think about it in the context of YouTube
and you mostly rely on the algorithm and
then like the old-school methods of you
know basically a guest post sooner like
you're on my vlog I'm on your vlog like
that's how it works
podcasting is pretty difficult but I
agree I really love the search on
breaker yeah that's the one thing that
all the other apps haven't done but yeah
yeah so download breaker alright yeah
next question what were your biggest
take aways from YC hmm I think part of
it is one of the great things about
being in YC is you are held accountable
and you're it's it's a it's almost like
to some extent school like you're your
professor is gonna be like did you read
the comp did you do the homework your
test results are gonna show like whether
you learn the thing or not at YC during
that three-month process I'm losing
track even you know you have this
accountability on a week over week basis
and you go into these group office hours
where you're sharing your updates and at
the time castor and Kevin Hale where our
group partners and they would ask
questions like alright did you do that
thing we talked about last week and so
it was a forcing function to just get
[ __ ] done because you don't have much
time and there's I think that mentality
is very healthy and well it is
uncomfortable and stressful in many
cases it's the best way to specially get
off the ground because you you just need
to do a lot of work and hold yourself
accountable I um always curious how how
the behavior changes after YC because
there's like there's this period of I
guess you producthunt wasn't around all
that long before you did YC right yeah
it was about five six months before we
actually entered right so you didn't
have that many defined habits yeah but
do you find yourself adapting like new
styles of running the team after YC or
is it pretty similar to the way you're
going about it before it's hard to say
why she was so focused in that initial
phase and then once we we raised a
series a basically right after YC and
then hired and so our process
changed and as it does when you hire
another five or ten people and so in
many ways we continued to have to change
things the way that we're doing things
effect we're still doing that now like
this next quarter like we might make
some changes in our process again hmm
partly just because it's you you see
what didn't go well last quarter and so
you want to change it so I don't know in
some ways I think a lot of it is YC
instills data-driven and like very
deliberate like talk to your customers
type of culture which I think is
something that I believe we had prior to
YC so for us maybe it didn't direct
dramatically change our culture the way
of operating so much um but it certainly
changed things in ways that I couldn't
probably realize just because you know
it's hard to know what we would be
without YC oh so okay cool
and so are you guys all you there were a
couple questions for you about remote
teams yeah what does your distribution
look like are you mostly in the Bay how
does it work yeah so we're about
two-thirds outside of a side of SF okay
so we have headquarters in SF and but
from the beginning we've been a
distributed team in fact the first
person that ended up while paying out of
pocket initially was Ricardo in Italy
and so he was a developer that came on
board and you know awesome guy and so
like from the very beginning we had sort
of a distributed team andreas came on
our CTO shortly after that and he was at
the time in Vienna now he's here in San
Francisco but we now have 17 people
across I think it's eight or nine time
zones from Bulgaria London Denver like
all over the board yeah and not just
like community moderation these people
are yeah developed yeah there's a
designer yeah yeah it's combination of
community and engineering actually
Julie's in Paris she joined a month or
two ago cool so which we need to hit
Asia we don't have anyone in Asia at
that's next on the list maybe so yeah if
you're looking for a job um okay and so
what are what are the learnings I mean
did you did you set out to build a
distributed team or was it just by
happenstance that you knew someone in
Italy and they could help
you know it it wasn't intentional in the
beginning it was almost a necessity
mm-hm and frankly because at the time
one not being an engineer I need to find
engineers and then Andreas and I
naturally came together and we both had
this passion for building this community
he then recruited a lot of the early
engineers who were based in Europe
because that's where a lot of his
network at the time was okay and so sort
of organically formed that way and then
in hindsight we realized there's a
couple huge advantages to distributed
teams like one you can hire anyone in
the world you don't need to hire people
just in San Francisco or people who want
to move here too it's very expensive to
hire in San Francisco of course like the
cost of living here is dramatically
higher than it is in Bulgaria and the
third piece too is is also very
competitive when it comes to hiring
especially for early-stage startup when
you're trying to take someone from like
Google or Facebook they're getting paid
I don't know $200,000 with like
beautiful cafeteria lunches you is like
a seed stage or pre funded company it's
like hard to convince them to come on
board so I think there's a lot of
benefits and building remote and
distribute teams the other kind of
fourth pieces also we get this global
perspective to some extent we're you
know half more than half the product and
communities actually outside the US and
I don't know for certain but I think
part of that is because our team itself
is distributed across the world and so
maybe there's this level of empathy or
understanding of like those communities
hmm
so I think we'll see I believe we'll see
more and more distribute teams more
remote workers it's sort of this
movement towards that direction and and
I think more people will be willing to
build teams like that because it's
easier to to work remotely with slack
and like various video chat apps like
zoom which we use and love so I'm happy
that we're distributed it does come with
challenges but overall it's a lot of
benefits yeah but nothing like outside
of the normal complaints and yeah
workflow yeah communication and you know
sometimes it's difficult when you have
overlap on maybe four hours working
together instead of like a full day yeah
but those are those are workable okay
yeah a few people asked about community
I think they're particularly excited
like
you know figuring out how you just got
started you know one person asked
Hattie's you asked how did you acquire
your first 1000 users sebastian mossad
asks how do you create a community so
quickly basically the same question yeah
how'd you get started what was your so
you started this email list but did you
have a following before online how did
it go
yeah so it started brought in some ways
started years before Prada hadn't
started in some some ways you know it's
before product and I mentioned earlier I
was writing a lot and I would love to
play with products and explore products
and write about I was running with like
a snapchat and all these other new apps
and new behaviours and I was just super
curious about you know why are people
engaged with these things you know I
helped near with his book hooked and did
more writing there and so I was building
a tiny bit of an audience not massive
not Kasey's and I like he's ridiculous
but a big enough audience within this
centered kind of tech community to the
point where when I did launch product
and when I announced the email I had
enough people following me to say oh I
know Ryan this looks cool I'm gonna try
it out and so it was combination of
having this first like a few hundred
people to sign up which was super
important and then also building
relationships with other founders and
investors and people that had known me
for a long time that made it exciting
and allowed them to be comfortable
joining and participating in the
community mm-hmm so the initial kind of
few first few hundred let's say or just
people that I built an audience or
following with for like years prior and
then after that when it launched it was
okay how do we grow this community
there's a couple thing tactics that we
did that one was press was actually a
great growth driver in the beginning and
so we we worked on getting press or
doing guest publishing actually wrote
ironically I wrote in Fast Company
something titled like how we got our
first 2,000 users read in limited yeah
and this was like way back when yeah and
it's ironic that I was writing about
that because my entire goal of writing
about that was to get you know another
thousand users yeah and that worked in
the beginning because you know probably
it was new to the tech engines
at that time and so people would sign up
and be like what is this thing so we did
things like that we also realized that
when makers and and founders saw their
product on producthunt naturally wanted
to join the conversation they wanted to
share it and so when we realized that I
would every morning go on Twitter and
like search for their Twitter username
and say hey Jill your product is is over
here people are talking about it do you
want to join in answer questions and
like 80% of the time they'd say yes of
course I'd love to so we did more of
that I just would spend first hour so my
day finding those makers online and
getting them involved and that led to
more and more growth hmm so it had a
natural kind of growth effect in the
beginning and those two tactics alone
we're like what led us to I don't know
several thousand people in the very
beginning and are the bots effective
still like you know I'm the
congratulations though those yeah yeah
yeah so for those that don't know we
have these these Twitter bots that we've
set up one of them is - so going back to
what I said before
first I would look for the the makers
and invite them it was all manual these
were like alright this is not scalable
let's productize this let's make this
scalable so then we allowed the
community to tag the makers and be like
here's a product I found here's Jack the
person that made it or whatever and we'd
asked like what's Jack's user name and
they would add it and then we'd have a
bot that would say hey Jack your product
was or you've been added as a maker to
this product here's the link and so that
would allow us to scale ibly sort of
recruit makers and that's been still
effective to this day no in fact makers
get upset if they are posted and they
don't realize it because they're like oh
I I couldn't answer questions or I
didn't have a chance to share it yeah so
we do make it like a an effort to make
sure they're they're notified that's
cool yeah it feels like a missed
opportunity I mean I love getting into
the comments like on a Chen product on
all that stuff so your growth now is it
coming more from the US or is it going
international as you find these other
types of people it's it's pretty even if
there's no we're not seeing necessarily
growth in a particular pocket it's it's
maybe unusual most startups you see very
let's start in the US are very us
centric and
you'll see 80% of their traffic or more
will be us from pretty early on we've
had a fairly international audience and
I think it's it's largely related to
where you see different startup hubs
around the world of course San Francisco
being a major one in New York and some
other cities in the US but there's also
you know places like like Paris and
Berlin and other places around the world
that have these communities of people
who love startups and they're building
products and so if you look at our like
Google Analytics like a heat map of
where people are a lot of it centers
around those start-up tech hubs actually
and those are everywhere so yeah for us
it's still quite international and it
always kind of has been when it comes to
the growth are there particular types of
products that come from particular areas
that you can kind of like group
automatically or distributed it's pretty
distributed yeah although there's some
trends we'll see I think for whatever
reason Paris is very design centric in
general so you'll see a lot of design
related or like beautiful looking
products coming from Paris or France in
general but I would love to do like an
analysis or something
we do have an API if anybody wants to
hack like something together use our API
to like come up with cool visualizations
okay that'd be cool have um have you
looked back at the products that you've
loved over the past couple years to
figure out if they're like three lines
for you in particular like this is what
you're attracted to like is a what I
like most your favorite kinds of
products it was like yeah by far the
most common question really what are
your favorite things would have to use
everything of that ilk
yeah well it's interesting if you look
at product in some cases is like a
representation of the theme at the time
or the trends so if you look back a
couple years ago let's say back when
Secret was blowing up there were a ton
of apps building anonymous social
experiences there were every single
almost day or week there was like
multiple different apps that were like
in that space because it was a time when
everyone is like this is working and
maybe there's an opportunity to build
new experiences around this theme
now today fast forward like things that
are built on blockchain and crypto of
course are super popular everything
there's at least two or three things
related to that and it's quite
interesting to see these trends happen
and like AI is kind of another one like
people using machine learning and AI in
part because there's a lot of
opportunity there but also like the
there's open source code and things that
you can use like introduce that to your
product so I don't know it's interesting
to see these trends over time me
personally I I like all kinds of things
in terms of I like to explore new ideas
and especially if people are using new
platforms and new interactions in in
different ways take voice for example
I'm pretty interested in voice based
applications like Lyle bird is one that
comes to mind which I think it was in
the last YC batch which it's kind of
crazy but you watched a demo and it
takes a sample of someone's voice and
then is able to recreate it to to create
basically make it sound like Obama is
saying something he never said so some
like crazy applications for that and
those are the types of products I get
really excited about because it's a lot
of about what product is about is really
like seeing what could be made in the
future what might change the world or at
least maybe a tiny part of your life
mm-hmm yeah it's a that was one of my
favorite companies and yeah it's amazing
it emulates your voice was like 20
minutes it can do it like perfect a
cursor
yeah cuz it's insane yeah I was gonna
define they open up the beta and I was
gonna record my voice and then I got
nervous I was like oh I mean we're
recording a podcast so you sort of have
my voice already but I was like we're
gonna use this against me
yeah no fake news is gonna be terrifying
have you seen the video emulations yes
yeah yeah bat with video emulation is
frightening yeah so when you see that
then you also think okay what's how do
we prevent against that how do we create
technology or products to help people
not you know fall into this this like a
hyper-realistic
fake news feature yeah has anyone
launched anything on product hunt that
uh addresses like watermarks or security
checks anything like that nothing that I
can think of right now that would be
interesting though yeah I'm sure there's
somebody out there doing it yeah well it
mean it's tricky because you got like
people believe what they want to believe
so like if you did any amount of
research now with a photo I used to do
Photoshop of the onion so like I did
that I like made fake news
professionally nice and yeah you know
you see like the article just gets
picked up in China and people just want
to believe it yeah that's just how it
goes
so yeah we're yeah we're headed toward a
world that's kind of scary it's gonna be
have there been any products that
launched on product hunt that didn't do
well and then proceeded to do very well
in the real world
oh I mean I'm sure tons like what I tell
people is like the number of up votes
you get on Pro 10 honestly doesn't mean
where they're gonna be successful or not
yeah I mean as that should be obvious to
people with some people they're really
disappointed like I got 20 up votes and
you know people don't like it well the
reality is launching is like a one-time
thing and whether your launch success
successful or not it's really like
startups is like a multi-year journey
mm-hmm
some of the most successful startups
really are like until year five six
seven is when they really are taking off
it takes a long time you don't hear
about those because you don't hear the
first four years usually nope so I'm
sure there's tons tons of them and the
other piece is like product n doesn't
today isn't encompassing everyone in the
world either so like if you're building
a product for a particular type of
audience that doesn't use product in
today then like it's probably not a
surprise that you didn't get a ton of up
votes or attention or whatever but then
yeah yeah totally it happens in YC all
the time
what are your pro tips for launching on
product huntin
yeah so part of it goes not to sound too
promotional but part of it is the reason
why we built ship so what we've what we
realized is a lot of people get into you
know a box and they build a product that
they think they love that the world will
love and maybe they will maybe they
won't but they don't really interact or
get feedback from a community nor do
they actually build an audience and get
people following them in advance not to
we keep talking about KC or I do but KC
is a good example like he he has
initially before they built the product
he built an audience and that audience
has grown more or more now no matter
what he puts out he's at least
guaranteed to get
people to care or try it out mm-hmm and
that's hugely valuable
you don't need KC's a live audience but
going back to my sort of product n if I
didn't have you know this first few
hundred people willing to sign up that I
had built that audience for over several
years I don't think probably it would
exist today mm-hmm so I think is a
combination of like my pro tips is like
one be okay with building an audience in
the sense that an audience of people
you're actually targeting and also
engage with those people get them
involved and get feedback from those
people early on and ship as design in
our hope is is it will help people do
exactly those two things yeah yeah I
mean I would say that I'm engaging with
the audience is something you guys do
super well it's like customer service is
highly yeah high up there and you're
high or ities customer service is seen
as like a cost under in many cases but
it's it's actually a great opportunity
to engage an audience like what they're
doing is they're coming to you and
saying I have a problem where I needs
help and many people many people are
like oh now they're coming to us but
like in reality it's like a great thing
people care enough to talk to you yeah
so we use Twitter heavily to interact
with people I have I use TweetDeck and I
command tab to it way too much and I
have a column for every single profit
convention and I see almost every single
one so I can see what people are talking
about what they're sharing if there's
issues that come up make sure that I
respond to them so small things that
make the community feel personable and
approachable is it ever overwhelming
with the amount of new stuff like I'm
constantly overwhelmed by the amount of
like cool things that come through YC
and that's just like a tiny fraction of
the world yeah do you ever have you
built up like an intense stamina for
like consuming new products or are there
ever points where you're just like I
don't need a new app today I mean I'm a
weirdo and then I just love doing this
stuff like exploring every single
morning waking up and seeing what people
are making so I'm an usual in essence I
also don't try to see everything
obviously it's kind of like some people
with their email they're like I gotta
get to inbox zero the reality is I don't
try to get an inbox zero it's just it's
just fine if it's not totally taken care
of so for me I know I don't mind
it like our hope with product and some
things were exploring is how do we
there's certain people weirdos like me
who love to consume the firehose and
there's some people who just tell me
like the cool one or two things this
week that I should know and so we're
exploring how do we appeal to both user
types you know making sure they don't
feel overwhelmed but making sure this
audience gets all the information they
need mm okay and is there an offering
for the one or two a week
yet the closest thing in we've offered
this for a while is our weekly digests
so we have a newsletter that goes out
either just on Mondays if you want or
Monday through Friday so the people who
are maybe less actively engaged but
still want to know like what happened
this week in the weekly digest and
that'll include like the most uploaded
products that week as well
pretty easy takes 10 seconds to consume
and a lot more consumable than like our
feed of just fire hoses and stuff absurd
it's crazy but it's crazy to see a grow
man they're like yeah yeah it's amazing
a bunch of random questions so akshar
i'm gonna mispronounce this akshar bone
ooh asked what is the most
counterintuitive thing you learned
building product on and then watching it
grow and be used I don't know if I have
a great answer for that one to be honest
I think there's things that internally
from a process and like leadership
standpoint that I don't know if I'd say
they're counterintuitive but it's
challenging to one thing I learned early
on as a product manager was I thought it
was being helpful in doing more of the
work so to put it make it more tangible
there's a time where I made a mess a
mistake of like basically changing one
of the UX designers work says like oh
it's this isn't quite exactly right to
spec let me just like spend the weekend
fix it and we'll save everyone time and
like I'll do him a favor I did the exact
opposite what it did was cause
frustration and ultimately I'm not a UX
designer in any way so like I shouldn't
be doing that work and I think that's
that lesson early on is something that I
think a lot of product managers or CEOs
or founders need to realize is that
you're used to doing all the work in the
beginning but as you grow a team you
alternately have to give up work and it
might feel like you're being less
productive and less effective but and
maybe you
are technically in the short-term but
long-term you need to want hire the
right people and then give them autonomy
to like build and do what they're good
at so that's I got a challenging almost
counter - and the thing I think for a
lot of people who are used to just doing
all the work yeah I think that's an
important learning and it's one that I'm
still kind of like grappling with on
side projects
that's just managing people well is
insanely high leverage like way higher
leverage then even if I was the best
programmer in the world
mm-hmm but it's hard when you get
satisfaction from making yeah yeah so
there are a couple angellist questions
so as now you're part of Angelus and
potentially related to the fund so a
mirror asks as part of Angelus has
product hunt considered investing
through a syndicate or other form in the
top featured products or even just the
top makers on product um yeah you know
early on I think the first like months
of product on some of our investors
actually were like Ryan you guys should
start a product an indica Tour fund of
some sort and at the time and even to
this day that was not important what I
realize is if we went down that route
what we would do is prioritize building
like a platform for investors and that's
ultimately not what we're set out to do
that doesn't mean we're not going to
build features for investors and make
those connections but that's a very
different community and a very different
product than a product discovery
platform for the world and so it's it's
funny of its I always been kind of a
theme or an opportunity that said we may
do things with the AngelList fundraising
team right now we're not actively doing
anything on the product side but what we
have been doing is bringing the
communities together and hosting dinners
and smaller meetups with founders and
investors um so nothing too crazy really
pretty lightweight but it's been a cool
way to bring these two communities
together who have a lot of overlap and
similarities mm-hmm and there's talk
though that you are now investing in
startups this is true yeah yeah so I the
day before I left for Burning Man
Axios spread some news about it which is
fine I wasn't meaning to announce
anything publicly but news got out there
and you know basically I've raised a
small fund using AngelList angel fund
platform which they announced it two or
three months ago it's sort of in beta
sort of quietly out there but basically
people are familiar with Angelus
syndicates for the most part which are
ways for people to raise money for a
particular deal or a particular company
they're great for for people who are
just getting into investing or they're
great for people who doing like giant SP
vs for very specific investments but
they're not as good for people doing
ongoing investments so they realise this
they've been working on it for several
months and they release angel funds
which is essentially this is a cheesy
way of saying it but it's like a VC in a
box in the sense that they do all the
work for you in setting up an actual VC
fund okay they do the legal paperwork
they set up the banks they even Samet on
the team is super helpful in talking to
LPS on the telephone like old-school
style it's like get them comfortable
with some like the side letters and
things like that so they do all of this
work that would normally cost maybe a
hundred thousand dollars to set up all
for like twelve thousand dollars and
they take a piece of the carry and as a
result you have a fun just like you
normally would and can invest in a
start-up just as a regular VC so it's
not deal by deal basis but you have
committee capital from LPS that you then
invest so I raised a fun after talking
to Nevada bunch of other people three
million dollar fund and just investing
in of course early-stage companies
everything from 50,000 to 200,000 and
yeah it's been been fun I called it
weekend fun wait it has a couple
different meanings for me well one I had
a spreadsheet of tons of different names
I was like what I want to call this
thing took me forever to come up with a
name that I liked but I really like
weekend fun because it has a few
different meanings one it's you know
product n is my full-time thing I'm
super super pumped still loving what I'm
doing in many ways we can find is like
my weekend side projects in some ways
weekend is also something like you see a
lot of founders starting projects in the
like product in itself that was like a
weekend nights and weekend project a lot
of those things start off is like really
humble and small
and grow into something big so it those
two meanings mean a lot to me and it's
it's also more friendly than like Hoover
capital or so yeah I don't know if
there's a hue tight there but the best
and do you have a particular thesis that
you're going for I imagine there are
tons of learnings from producthunt
what's your what's your goal you know
it's intentionally fairly open in that
I'm not strictly defining or looking at
a like e-commerce or biotech space in
fact I'm excited to invest in areas that
I could be helpful in first like
actually biotech is a place where I'm
probably not going to be as helpful as I
would with maybe a community-based
product as an example so a lot of it is
trying to invest in companies I think I
can be helpful with there are some areas
and I'm particularly interested in like
we talked about remote and distributed
teams I'm very interested in people
building products and tools and things
for this new future where we're seeing
more distributed teams and and people
working remotely I also see voices a
really interesting space it's hard to
know exactly what voice will play in
people's lives but inevitably voice will
change the way people interact with
technology in in different ways
like my Google home right now is my
audio player it's just easier than
opening my iPhone to like play Rufus to
Seoul or whatever mm-hm
so those are two areas I'm like
particularly interested in but you know
the the investments I've done now to
date have ironically been a little bit
community focus which is something I
have experienced I run it I guess not
ironic yeah but those are things that I
get excited about and okay and want to
support so we have another interview
coming up actually later today with
Courtland from indie hackers okay and
you asked him a question but I'm gonna
ask it back to you and that is asked I
forgot it is what do you believe that
most others do not
oh man oh my face I finally face of
course I added a smiley face oh man I
asked this question I don't have a good
answer for myself you know I think this
I think 50% of the people in technology
will agree and maybe 50% won't I think
that
this technology is makes the world
ultimately better and there's certainly
some downsides that you see in negative
things that happen in startups and
technology but ultimately like
technology is like this this water is
here because I can drink this because of
technology and I always believed that
progressing in more startups and
founders and people succeeding is
ultimately good for the world but more
specifically I think the extreme future
that you read about in sci-fi books and
see in movies I think the world where we
live in VR is actually a good thing and
I know a lot of people get really scared
and nervous about like a future where we
all live in like a ready player one or
at least like some sort of virtual world
like that I actually think it's a
awesome thing and the reason for that is
ultimately if you can recreate and build
relationships and live a life that's in
a better world than your own like we
live in a great place and and we're very
fortunate but a lot of people are not
and they live in in you know dirt shacks
and if they could escape and and go to a
different world and live there that
seems like a great thing so I know
there's a lot of negative things that
can come from a world where people live
in a virtual reality but I also almost
don't see a future where at some point
that's where majority people spend their
lives because we're already pretty close
like this phone in my pocket and my
computer screen I already live inside of
that most of the day mm-hm and I think
most people do or they watch TV like the
average American it's I forget if it's
four hours at eight hours a day but it's
something crazy they watch a lot of TV
and you you can kind of imagine that
extending into that that screen and that
technology extending into their everyday
life through VR and AR and other things
like that so I think it's a good thing I
think we should embrace it and be
responsible with it but also I I don't
think it's a bad thing that people live
inside of technology differently how
much time do you spend in VR on an
average day I actually don't spend any
time I don't have any of your equipment
maybe I have a Samsung headset somewhere
in a gear VR but I don't right now it's
- I haven't found an application that I
really enjoy and it's too cumbersome too
heavy but eventually it's going to be
you know a glasses it's gonna be
comfortable eventually it'll be in my
car
say I feel like anything you can imagine
almost will happen at some point is just
a matter of time
yeah and so I just don't see a world we
don't have that it's almost like will it
will happen in my lifetime not sure I
bet it will yeah I also completely agree
with you that event the fact that like
just because your life in San Francisco
is great doesn't mean that other people
wouldn't want to be LeBron James for
four hours a day yeah yeah if you could
you'd fly I mean there's so many cool
things that I wish I could do and I
already live a very fortunate awesome
life here and the other piece to that
too is like of course VR is not
accessible to the people in the dirt
shacks right now today but technology it
innovates and it becomes accessible to
let's say the 1% and then it becomes
more accessible to more and more people
and then the price is lower and lower
and lower so it's a I guess I want to
mention that point because I don't want
to say like oh how is is someone like
that who makes you know 20 bucks a month
you can afford oculus well just imagine
a future where inevitably it's becomes
almost free yeah and I think I think
that's inevitable t I mean if you just
like look at the graph of smartphone
distribution and said yeah saying yeah
and the prices are going up - you can
buy $1000 iPhone now I know that's for
like the 64 gigabyte I think one mistake
any other ones more yeah like a 256 I
don't know what the price is but you can
expect 13 14 - probably
alright so yeah I guess that's probably
the last question so Soren asks what
does Ryan think of the rising crypto
assets and their implementation and
products hmm oh so it's something I've
been I've been following this base of
course but I've not dug in nearly as
much as some other people I actually
don't well I own a little bit of file
coin but I don't own any other
cryptocurrencies so I haven't actually
taken the plunge
maybe I should well I certainly should
have but but I think it's a what I will
say is that one it's really interesting
when you see these these almost like
greenfield opportunities mmm and new
platform shifts like we've talked about
voice a little bit and how that has a
potential to change behavior and create
new
variances same thing with blockchain and
crypto and other things like that it has
an opportunity to open up new pathways
open up new doors for makers and
founders and companies to create new
experiences that may actually change
people's behavior dramatically I mean
we're already seeing this to some extent
with fundraising people are launching an
ICO instead of going to VCS and you know
the deals they're getting it's like I'm
it's unheard of like you basically are
getting way more money and you don't
have investors to pay back like you own
everything and I mean there's just a lot
of like crazy things that flips
everything on its head and so there's a
lot of interesting things happening
there angeles's has been you know
working with coin list and and trying to
legitimize and bring some trust to the
platform and in the ecosystem but
honestly I think even the people who are
deep into or still like I'm not sure
where this is gonna go yet it's hard to
predict it's the same somebody I forgot
who it was I wish I could credit them is
it's hard to predict you know early in
the the world-wide-web day is like is
that that a Facebook would be you think
like it's hard to extrapolate and go
that far because you just don't have the
mental model or the infrastructure built
yet to imagine what's gonna be created
with this in two three four years mm-hmm
great actually last question how do you
spend your spare time what do you do for
fun
I love maybe in the past two to three
years I've enjoyed going to concerts and
seeing live music more and more I went
to Coachella back in 2015 and that was
one of those aha moments I was like this
is so fun this is great like go there
were some great fans go dancing listen
to good music and so loved loved doing
that I also just love I love my alone
time and going I go to Phil's all the
time that's where probably had started
actually it was you know Phil's coffee
shop and I enjoy on the weekends
especially like going there and catching
up on work and it was a weird thing but
I'll get get up at 6 a.m. to probably
tomorrow and just work and hang out and
drink coffee so I know normal stuff I
guess cool all right thanks man yeah
thanks
you